most of us associate oil reserves with
enormous amounts of wealth and this is
for good reason oil has become one of
the most sought after commodities in the
world which has a lot of countries with
notable oil reserves to rise to the
absolute top saudi arabia for example
has cash and gold reserves that total
nearly half a trillion dollars
similarly saudi arabia's flagship
company saudi aramco is currently
profiting over a quarter trillion
dollars per year considering this you
would think that any country with
reserves that are comparable to saudi
arabia would be filthy rich but this is
actually not the case in fact saudi
arabia doesn't even have the world's
largest oil reserves this title actually
goes to venezuela who has roughly 300
billion barrels of oil that's nearly
one-fifth of the entire world's oil
reserves yet despite this venezuela
isn't particularly well-off or rich
they're actually particularly poor and
struggling for one they recently
experienced some of the worst
hyperinflation known to mankind with
inflation peaking in the hundreds of
thousands of percent ten years ago you
could only get 4.3 venezuelan boulevards
for one us dollar but by late last year
you could get 419 billion boulevards
with just one us dollar this number has
since plummeted to 782 thousand
boulevards per dollar
but that's not because inflation is
cooling down
rather this is actually because the
government decided to divide their
currency notes by a million so without
this conversion each us dollar would
actually be able to get nearly 800
billion boulevards fortunately the
country has an oil revenue to rely on
but this hasn't been nearly as helpful
as you might think oil accounts for
roughly 25 percent of venezuela's gdp
with the gdp of 482 billion dollars this
means that oil accounts for roughly 120
billion worth of gdp
while this is not a bad figure when you
consider that saudi aramco itself is
able to pull in net profits that are
over double this figure you start to see
just how behind venezuela really is so
why is venezuela so poor despite having
the world's largest oil reserves
taking a look back it's definitely not a
lack of crying that has screwed over
venezuela in fact venezuela has been
trying to capitalize on their oil
reserves for over a hundred years it all
started in the year 1908 when a man
named juan vicente gomez became the
president of venezuela gomez was an
ambitious man who wanted to slash
venezuelan dead and revolutionized the
country and the way he sought to
accomplish this was by leveraging the
country's oil reserves at the time
people knew that venezuela had enough
oil for commercial purposes but no one
could have imagined the full magnitude
of just how much was actually available
president gomez however was willing to
roll the dice and test the country's
luck so he handed out oil concessions to
his closest friends and told them to go
enrich themselves and the country these
guys would turn around and hire oil
companies to come in and begin to hunt
within the next several years these
companies would find several viable oil
reserves however the blowout discovery
didn't come to 1922 when shell struck
oil in the maracaibo basin this well was
able to produce over a hundred thousand
barrels of oil per day by itself as you
would guess it didn't take long for more
oil companies to flood in it and they
were able to pump up annual production
to 137 million barrels of oil by the end
of the 1920s for perspective saudi
arabia didn't find oil till 1938 so
venezuela definitely had the first
mover's advantage but what they didn't
have was good management you see when
you find oil it's not as simple as just
cashing in the checks and living the
high life you have to reinvest the
profits and diversify the economy if you
want the money to actually create a
long-term change president gomez however
didn't do either of these now this isn't
to say that he spent the money in four
ways per se
of course he enriched himself and his
friends but he also spent significant
amounts on public projects and slashing
the country's debt this might seem like
a good use of money but it actually
leads to a phenomenon called dutch
disease dutch disease is when a country
experiences a massive influx of economic
growth within one sector which diverts
the entire country's focus
everyone suddenly wants to work in this
one industry or open a business in this
industry and while it's definitely a
good idea to follow opportunity this
sort of behavior leads to the rest of
the economy to fall to the wayside and
become underdeveloped in relation in
other words the country becomes overly
dependent on just one part of the
economy and this is exactly what
happened in venezuela given that oil
accounted for 90 of their exports by the
time gomez died this situation has only
gotten worse over the years as the oil
accounts for 95 of venezuela's exports
today but at the time the venezuelans
didn't realize what was ahead of them
and they would simply lean further into
their oil dependence
now that venezuela had proven their
viability to the western world it was
them who had the leverage you see in the
beginning it was the other way around
all these oil companies had to come in
and make a massive gamble on venezuela
but now that that gamble had proven
fruitful venezuela could start making
demands one of the first demands the
country made was for a larger proportion
of the oil revenue to flow into the
government in 1943 the government
introduced the hydrocarbons law which
required that foreign companies hand
over half of their oil profits to the
state this proved to be extremely
lucrative as venezuela's income would
grow six-fold in the following five
years but venezuela was just getting
started over the next few decades
venezuela would slowly nationalize the
entire oil industry in the meantime they
were also pushing for political reform
and trying to escape a history of
dictators one piece of this puzzle was
the punto fijo pact in 1958 this
agreement stipulated that the oil money
would be split between the three main
political parties in venezuela and the
respective proportions would be
determined by the popular vote at first
glance this sounds like a decent system
by splitting up the oil money you
ensured that one political party
couldn't just overpower the others but
at the same time it is also opened up
the country to loads of embezzlement i
mean who was going to make sure that
these political parties would actually
use the money in effective methods the
answer is no one while this storm was
starting to brew inside venezuela to the
rest of the world it seemed like
venezuela was killing it in 1960 they
would join up with the middle eastern
countries to found opec this was
essentially an agreement that these
countries would work together to
maximize all profits for all member
countries and now that venezuela had the
middle east on their side they were able
to become even more aggressive with
their own oil endeavors that same year
venezuela established a state-owned oil
company and increased taxes on oil
companies to 65
at this point it was just a matter of
time until venezuela nationalized oil
production all it would take is one more
monumental event and that's exactly what
would happen in the 1970s with the oil
embargo in 1973 opec would implement a
five-month embargo on countries that
supported israel in the yom kippur war
and one of these countries was the
united states as all of america's demand
shifted to non-opec countries oil prices
would quadrupola which was extremely
lucrative for all oil producing
countries but especially venezuela
venezuela would end up boasting the
highest per capita income in latin
america and this is exactly the push
they needed to completely nationalize
the country's oil production in 1976.
normally this would be a good thing it
wasn't until saudi arabia nationalized
their oil production that they became
stupid rich but the problem with
venezuela was that they had a massive
leak when it came to oil revenue due to
corruption and nationalization just
kicked this issue into full year between
1972 and 1997 it's estimated that 100
billion worth of oil money was embezzled
by politicians and government officials
with that sort of leak it's no wonder
why venezuela ended up where they are
today
at this point you might be thinking that
things can't get much worse but they did
because a socialist named hugo chavez
would become president in 1998. during
this time period everyday venezuelans
were livid because everyone knew what
was happening politicians were siphoning
national money like there was no
tomorrow so when chavez came in with
this pitch of welfare and equality for
all the venezuelans ate it up
now people often like to blame chavez
for venezuela's downfall and this makes
sense given that he was the reason but
you can't really blame him because he
didn't really do anything that he didn't
say he was gonna do he truly believed in
socialism and he campaigned on the
premise that he would implement
socialism and that's exactly what he did
he took all the oil money and created
loads of social programs focusing on
justice welfare poverty education the
military and so on he also peddled
socialist ideologies that often led to
horrendous results in one of his most
famous speeches for example he
essentially declared that it was okay to
steal if you were hungry honestly i
think he had good intentions when he
said this but what this resulted in was
loads of crime meanwhile his social
programs were simply feeding into dutch
disease as more people started relying
on these welfare programs the other
industries in venezuela plummeted to
record lows while dependence on oil rose
to record highs also we should note that
chavez didn't really do anything to fix
the corruption problem if anything he
partook in the same activities as he
would eventually grow to be a
billionaire while chavez was growing his
world venezuela was quickly losing
theirs take the 2002 venezuelan awe
strike for example tens of thousands of
oil workers would go on strike and
demand for a new election to replace
chavez instead of addressing their
concerns though chavez would just go
ahead and fire 18 000 oil workers while
chavez was definitely able to show who
was in charge this would take a massive
toll on the country's oil production
venezuela was not only becoming more
dependent on oil revenue but our
production was declining this was simply
a disaster waiting to happen but chavez
would actually never see the
consequences as he would die due to
health problems in march of 2013
less than a year later oil prices would
crash because saudi arabia would decide
to start a price war the entire world
would feel the pain of their actions but
most of them would survive to see the
other side the same however could not be
said about venezuela
given that venezuela was basically 100
dependent on oil when this crash and
prices took place the country's economy
basically fell off a cliff the
government would try to stimulate the
economy by printing money and injecting
it into the economy but the problem was
that there was nothing to stimulate
venezuela had no economy it was just oil
and that's it so when oil went belly up
the country went the belly up and it was
no time before hyperinflation settled in
and that brings us to where we are today
looking back it's not like venezuela was
not able to leverage their resources or
pump up production or pulling loads of
money the problem is that none of this
money actually went to anything useful
virtually all of it went to corruption
and social programs when it should have
gone to developing the economy over time
venezuela's economic development just
became more and more uneven until they
became fully dependent on oil revenue
and at this point it just took one
downturn in the oil market to wipe out
the entire country and that's why
venezuela is dirt poor despite having
the world's largest oil reserves on the
bright side they still have those oil
reserves so do you think venezuela can
turn things around comment that down
below also drop a like if you hope
things get better in venezuela
and of course consider checking out our
discord community to suggest for the
video ideas and then consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then i'm
hari and i'll see you guys on the next
one
you